Це поле розташоване недалеко від болгарської столиці Софії.
Тут вночі наприкінці вересня Дімітар Стоянов
зі своїм колегою знайшов палаючі папери -
офіційні документи.
Інформатор дав активістам-антикорупціонерам наводку.
Це металеві частини папок.
А це - офіційні документи
з міністерства культури.
Тут, як стверджує Стоянов, хотіли знищити
докази розтрати грошей, виділених ЄС
на фінансування будівельних проектів.
Ось тут сховалися поліцейські.
Ми приїхали сюди, стали світити ліхтариками на мобільних,
знайшли документи. І тут раптом вистрибують поліцейські
і наказують нам лягти на землю. В них були ліхтарі і зброя.
Стоянов підозрює, що поліцейським дали хабар,
щоб вони проконтролювали знищення документів.
Причини вагомі, адже йдеться про шахрайство на мільярди.
Я думаю, що ми знайшли таблиці з цифрами цих шахрайських схем.
Чорна бухгалтерія, докази того, хто кому і як давав хабарі.
GP Group болгарська будівельна компанія,
потрапила у фокус розслідування активістів.
Імовірно, Джі Пі Груп давала хабарі іншим фірмам,
щоб отримати фальшиві позитивні рекомендації
для своїх заявок у ЄС.
Таким чином GP Group вдалося отримати багато замовлень
і відповідно євросоюзівських грошей.
Стоянов називає два приклади - це будівництво нової гілки метро в Софії
та оновлення пішохідної зони в центрі міста.
З 2007 по 2021 роки
Болгарія має отримати приблизно 15 мільярдів євро.
На жаль, ми припускаємо, що більша частина цих грошей
осіла в кишенях корумпованих чиновників.
Після публікацій Дімітара Стоянова
заступник прем'єр-міністра доручив прокуратурі  перевірити ці підозри в корупції.
Але сам політик вважає, що Болгарію звинувачують несправедливо.
Я знаю, що для Європи іноді зручно, щоб Болгарія
грала роль поганої. Ми - новий член ЄС,
відносно маленька і бідна країна. Але це нечесно.
Руслан Стефанов працює в Центрі демократичних досліджень.
Він називає подібні висловлювання окозамилюванням.
У нас ще не було масштабних розслідувань щодо уряду.
навпаки, є маса прикладів, коли обвинувачені, які брали участь
у тендерах і які мають зв'язки в політиці,
не були засуджені. Навіть якщо були докази корупції.
Стоянов показує нам інші документи чорної бухгалтерії GP Group
Але щоб оприлюднити їх, у нього не дуже багато шансів.
Більшість ЗМІ, каже Стоянов, належать або олігархам, або державі.
У цих ЗМІ прем'єр-міністр Болгарії Бойко Борисов
нині пожинає лаври за свій буцімто жорсткий підхід
у будівельному скандалі.
Тут написано: Борисов розпорядився виключити
GP Group з проектів Євросоюзу.
Звучить красиво, але не так, як у правовій державі, вважає Стоянов.
Якщо прем'єр-міністр раптом заявляє, що компанія позбавляється
права здійснювати проекти, тому що підозрюється в корупції,
але ще немає рішення суду, то це більше схоже
на диктатуру російського або турецького штибу.
Адже не можна боротися з корупцією,
використовуючи державне свавілля.
Попри всі перепони викриття Дімітара Стоянова
все ж спричинили в Болгарії великий резонанс.
Але чи будуть інші наслідки, в цьому активісти сумніваються.